so kelsey you're such a versatile actor
you're an amazing actor
but i gotta say i don't think i ever
thought
i would see you singing songs written by
rivers cuomo from weezer
what was that experience like pretty
cool i like him
you know you know really talented guy
and uh
rachel windsor who directed the film
also talked extensively with him about
the kind of songs that seemed you know
right that were like
from that time that would be would be
kegged with that kind of history around
the early 70s
and uh he apparently said that he you
know changed the way he wrote music
sounded to accommodate
those those things and that's a really
creative guy um yeah
i hoped that he liked him you know i
mean i still don't really know but he
says he kind of liked him but i mean
you know because i was saying his music
no yeah
but uh as this character mickey which
was uh
two different characters basically
because he's young and many told so the
vocal performances are mostly young
so sort of album stuff yeah
yeah there's one nice kind of quiet
moment where they actually do play out a
whole song
which is uh is sort of a valid
sweet melody thing introspective which
is a
lovely tune but yeah i like them yeah
yeah thank you
backgrounds or just sort of i really
like that you know maybe we'll get to
know him sometime
but the last one where i finally sing
about my daughter and stuff
just kill her yeah no absolutely
is it true that you had like ambitions
to be a singer like early in your career
like to be a full professional
yeah yeah i started out singing in
churches and choir in high school
and then actually then i did a play i
did a plan toward my
junior year i guess and a good senior
year i
thought oh this is kind of a nice way to
make a living
[Laughter]
new york yeah was that one of the
reasons that this character
to you like to get back into like like
playing a musician yeah it used to be
big
in so many ways because you know i
recognize this guy
i i wanted to be a guy like this when i
was a kid because i mean you know
i was running across yourself nationally
i mean all these things happened and
everything was
everything was about how much we
believed in things and how positive that
generation was
how beautiful it was to like express
yourself and be creative
and you know and but it
it was a whole lifestyle i thought well
i'd love to live that way
oh right yeah no i i didn't get it but i
got something close
yeah i had to go back and
yeah did you look at any real-life
musicians for inspiration
well um mickey adams is based on
i mean it's not you know a direct lift
but on a good friend of mine ray kennedy
was his name he's going oh yeah
but uh he was a songwriter wrote a lot
of music a lot of music that people
would recognize
and uh we just became fast fast friends
from when i moved to l.a i met ray
and uh you know he'd come over the house
and play a music chord like cows come
write a song with me come on man
you know we never really quite got off
the ground with that stuff but i always
felt bad about it
so this is this is right yeah this is
right for me
and a little bit of robert yeah that's
amazing
yeah so i was thinking like i mean
playing frasier you've played play
frasier for 22 years
when you're not playing that role are
you very conscious of
you know the types of roles you want to
do like i want to do a play i want to
yeah
um there's um there's a certain sort of
muscle memory that uh
comes along to ride in certain uh venues
like television people kind of
always want to think you know oh that's
that's where frasier lives
um but you know we got to kind of blow
that out of the water when i did the
show called boss which was
right pretty serious drama and uh so
that was fun but i'm i am drawn to roles
that are not freaking
you know frasier because i mean i i do
that in one place that's fine
frasier world yeah that's great yeah the
other guys i mean when you do a movie
arguably
you're getting a chance to try something
else and
this character really was that on
steroids mickey adams is you know
he's he's just a guy that exists in some
other place and i got to play him
yeah that's the thing like it was great
watching you play this role like what
did you get out of playing this role
oh just uh you know what you're doing
at least for me when i'm an actor i want
to feel like i did something true
uh there's a great book about
shakespeare called the true lie
um great art is a true lie because
everybody knows it's not the truth but
it is the truth it's sort of like
supernatural and uh
i know when things are working when i
know that i'm connected to that
source that energy and uh mickey was
like there the whole time
he was just yeah that guy's got the
biggest heart he's sort of like orson
welles it's just a
giant character who has a giant heart
who has a love that you know of life
that's irrepressible even through this
horrible nightmare of the life he's had
he also has a wonderful life and he
doesn't quit he's not a quitter and
that's i love him
yeah it's funny we interviewed your
daughter uh spencer just about a month
ago and she said she learned comedic
timing from you and she told that to you
she has told me she's proud of me yeah
but uh we had dinner last night actually
i was in new york city last night and uh
we uh had a a great meal and she wrote
back and texted him that
he's just the funniest man he's so smart
it's just a lovely thing
here you know it's like you want your
kids to like you you know
yeah exactly you know we finally got to
where that happened
yeah what's it like to see her
succeeding in the business now fantastic
i'm so proud i mean she's got this new
show out on nickelodeon called barbarian
and the troll
which my kids love my new my new batch
you know i gave you my six-year-old son
yeah he's in love with her and when when
i see spencer's name after spencer
grammer
um it's just i'm over the moon about it
yeah she also said she was joking when
she said it but she thinks because she
was talking about the fraser revival she
said
she doesn't think you ever stopped being
frazier even at home
do you know what she means by that no
i excuse being smart
are the things that are recognizable
about me is
if i were to say what's what's this the
things you share with frasier
i share a quality of life um
desire with him i like style
i like beauty i like great art stuff
like that
yeah you know i'm always falling short
of the mark in terms of what i think
life should be
but i'm never quitting either so you
know my freezer's a little like that
fraser got beat down every damn day
and get kept going so keeps coming back
yeah
i know you've been tight-lipped about
the revival like have you decided what
his third act is now
yeah we're pretty much online with that
i mean you know yeah races like george
bailey you know in a wonderful life
he's just about to go do the thing he
loves to do he thinks he's going to love
to do he's going to go explore whatever
he's got his suitcase packed and
something pulls him back and
uh so this is that'll happen again
basically and he's got
something more important to do i could
see him being a musician like even
watching this movie i was like i see
frasier being magician
yeah that's that's the next step
certainly
vegas yeah i do want to ask you two um
the alec baldwin to come is that dead
like you guys still trying to make that
happen
no it's it's it's just dead i i think
that's what happens you know these two
guys yeah
brought them up and then uh um uh abc
must have developed a great season
because i mean we were pretty good we
were pretty funny
so uh you know they've got i'll i'm
anxious to see it
cause i'm sure absolutely yeah that's
yeah it's so much fun to see in this
role yeah i can't wait to see the yeah
the revival phrase
have you have you talked to their cast
members like david perry
jane if you had any conversations yeah
awesome that's awesome well yeah
congratulations on this movie yeah it's
so fun to see in this role
yeah great to talk to you today very
much
you